Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to DOOM.
I forgot . . .
that I started this episode at the top of this tower
so we're just gonna skedaddle on up
(Manly squeal)
Uuuuuh
That's how I use the weapon wheel
Okay we're back
This is actually kinda handy
because . . .
Uuuh . . . Eh
Because I have so many weapons
It's often hard to reach
Like, I want the 8 button pressed
But it's kinda hard to get to it so
This actually makes it a little bit easier
I mean obviously the main weapons are
simple to get to and my old reliable is at number 2
So always available.
Oh, Hey!
VEGA!
You look . . .
Different than I imagined you'd look
I mean in a good way
I don't wanna be insulting about it with your whole
Brain style operation going on here.
Kinda reminiscent of . . .
The . . .
Mastermind Demon
I forget what is
The Spider Brain
Whatever it was
Spider Demon
I forget what it was called
Ooh
There's a lot of rumblies going on down here
Man! They just needed all this just to be able to power this facility?
That doesn't make any sense
Uh-huh
VEGA Central Processing
Neural lock protection active.
It's almost as if they didn't want people blowing it the feck up!
Boink.
S'cuse me.
Sorry VEGA
Not really
Uhhh-huuuh
Okaay
Alright movin' on.
That was almost exactly what I needed to do.
Seems like a lot of my tasks in this game seem to be
dismantling everything that humanity has built thus far.
Man, it seems that argent energy even runs through VEGA.
I mean now I'm just assuming whenever I see
red lightning shooting out of everywhere I'm assuming that's . . .
Oh! Initiate core destruction.
Hmm!
Oh!
Well that's cute! I - I made a backup of VEGA.
I had like a moment of hesitation there.
It was like "Ohhh, be nice to him"
Wow, I did nothing in that map!
I did nothing!
Probably cause I was having so much trouble with it that
my brain was frazzled.
But . . . That's interesting!
Why did VEGA say . . .
That he had so many regrets?
Why would an A.I. have regrets?
Now, this is what I wonder.
When it comes to Hell and what Hell is.
Is Hell an entirely different like dimension?
Is it a different universe?
Like, how do they describe it?
And when it comes to the entire size of Hell
I imagine that it's not exactly a planet
It's like a plane of existence
And if that is the case
Then Hell is infinitely big just like our universe is
And that, poses a lot of questions. Like . . .
How do the demons get around? How do they communicate?
How do they coordinate?
Again I worry about you know all the pumpage of the.. blood everywhere
Cuz they seem to have a very coordinated system about that
But loo--just looking out on this like horizon
There's no land
Like that's not...I...
There ain't nothin down there
It's just...
Goodbyehahahahayeeeeee
Yeah
So it's just bizar- I guess there might be land down there but
I don't imagine
That it's a planet in any sense that we would understand but
I-I don't know if it's infinitely large or contained to a smaller area
Who would know?
And frankly who could care?
It's only me that's gonna be wondering about these bizarre things
Hmm
Oh a throne?
Is that my seat?
I hear some moaning in the distance but I guess that-
oooh
Whoa what was going on there?  Hang on
Whoa I didn't notice the hands at first
That's a little bizarre
I'm sure there's something very important written there
And I'll probably blow it up at some point in my life :)
oooh wait a minute
Wait a second!
Hold a tick, that's ME
That is 100% me in my current armor right now
Okay thanks for putting this, that's my symbol
Right between my legs I guess, okay
mmkay and that's the facility on Mars and the well must be over there
Okay enough ogling at the horizon
We got a mission to accomplish here so let's do it
(old man noise)
(random mark noises)
Light as a feather
Huh
Oh what's that?
An imp?
Ha! You walked right into my trap
Well I mean, not really
Maybe this guy did
Wahaha see?
You walked right into it
Totally, voluntarily walked into that shit
Whoa hey!
What are you doing here?
Okay, woosh
Whoa he still moves kinda quick when he's
when he's being froozed
That's actually kinda nice cuz it gives me
Like a little moment of breathing room
Like oh I want the super shotgun for the-, where's the-, there it is
Boink
Boink!
Eh! there we go
Whoop
Almost, there I got him
Ah was that a summoner?
Better get out the Gauss Cannon
Whoop! Poink!
Oh he's dead already
Oh shit
aaaa boink!
Ah ha ha got ya right in the butt
Whoop boink!
hohohoho hello
AH stop messing around
I gotta stop being a dick about this
Woo shit where am I going?
Whoa
Ah fuck
Oh shit that ain't good
Alright I need a different weapon
Uhh this'll do
Please and thank you
PLEASE and thank you
Please die, die, die
Oh shit, the overheating, I forgot about that
Oh boy
Di--Whoa fuck me!
Whoa AH! Oh god dammit that wasn't supposed to hit me
I might die
I literally might die if I can't get this guy out
Whoa shit
Wahahahahaha that got me a lot of shit
Hubbeduh hubbeduh
Ah fuck
Okay
Can I just, get behind you please
Please? Pretty please? God dammit
Okay. Whoa gonna getcha gonna getcha gonna getcha
Whoopee ha ha ha ha
*anime voice* You've activated my trap card
I mean none of these guys is a pla--
I don't think they play Yugioh in hell
And maybe that's ALL they play. I have no idea
Who am I to say?
I don't know if any of my fans out there still play Yugioh
I never did!
I was uh
I was more of a Magic the Gathering type of guy
I don't know why I'm talking about this at this point when I'm
Battling the denizens of hell
Where does this go?
Whoa! Where did I go?
Okay
Alright
Well that didn't tell me a whole lot
BOINK
Hey buddy
Whoo! Whoa hey wait whoa whoa
Can I just doh-
Oh! did that not get you?!
Really??
Ah shit
K that guy's dunzo
No you're not dunzo. Holy shit AH
You're not dunzo either. Fuck!
Ahkay yes, yes please, yes please! Yes please!
Thank you
Where the frick? There ya are
God dammit you're, you're feisty
You're, you're, you're less feisty
alright
Ah shit. Man they are just going all out on me today
Holy frick
I-I'm runnin out of ammo here I gotta
I gotta cut up a little guy
Here you go, 'ey, 'ey 'ey! Come here
Oh is that a berserk?
Was that a berserk? Was that a-
Omg it's a berserk!
YES
YES! It's everything I could've hoped for
Oh god what am I hitting? I don't even know OH sorry
Didn't see ya there
OOP!  Ba-dum!
Okay, anbody else?
Whoa shit. You came at the wrong time buddy boo
Whoop sorry catch ya around the corner
*anime voice* Heh! This is what I planned all along
With the trap card that I was talking about so much
Remember?
The thing I said about traps?
All planned from the very beginning
Okay
I like the perk that makes this last a lot longer
because that's MUCH more useful
And I wish I would've seen that earlier on but..
I'm a big dumb doofy doo (yes, yes you are)
As I've said many times throughout my existence, I'm a big dumb doofy doo
Okay
So now that we did that
I do not see any...secrets down here
This is just a big battle arena
And god damn that was almost it for me like 3 times out there
I'm trying to play good
I'm trying to play real good
But sometimes it doesn't work out for me- oh I was supposed to go this way, sorry
Didn't quite see
I lost where I was--
What the fuck is that?
Eh, it just seems like the whole like
Area that we're in grows...
Like, flesh
And intestines and what I think is like piping
Is actually the entire plane of hell
Is alive
And that's bizarre
Hey!  I saw that in my dreams. Why is it guarded by statues of mah bros?
The crusader bros
Cuz I remember them in my dreams
Also am I getting close to the end of the game?
Oh hey
Someone's having somethin- someone choking?
Anyone know the Heimlich?
Okay
So they're underneath me
And I cant really see anything much more from where I am and there's a button over there, okay.
Let's just do dis
Hibooshki
Yeah that probably triggered something bad
Hep!
Ah meant to hit ya
Boink
Alright
So far so good
Pushin' random buttons in hell usually doesn't end so nicely
Ehh
Alright
Oh no
Huh
Okay
Alright
Huh
Am I supposed to go off one of the side routes or am I just supposed to go straight for this thing?
Oh can I not go s-- OH okay
Oh I thought this was leading right to it
I thought I was trying to be sneaky about it and go around but
Apparently I missed out
There's a path down to the right
That I could definitely take and there was a path up to the left
Both seem viable but this seems more
Like secluded so I-I'm...I'm willing to bet this one leads to a bit more secretive- ooh
Hello!
No just, oh I hate you guys so much
NO
he he he he he woo
Alright
Still don't know- whoa! hey!
God dammit dude!
You're gonna chew up my armor. Ah fuck you dude!
God dammit all these dudes ain't, ain't being nice :(
They're not being coool
And that's what I demand about everyone that I interact with
Is that they be super cool
Alright let's go chaingun
Cuz NOOOOOOO
(fart noise)
Okay, here we go
This is pretty powerful, I will admit
I don't- for some reason I-I don't go with the heavier style of weapons
As much as I think I should
Like I don't go for the super shotgun because I like the grenade launcher so much
But i think it's like
Way more damage per shell
With the super shotgun than it is with the normal shotgun
But I don't know if that balances out to anything else
With the uh
Grenade launcher
I just think the utility of it is so nice
I wanna be diverse but I'm a boring person at heart
I really don't try anything special
I'm just so secluded in everything that I attempt it's not fun
Aw I missed the automap up there. Ah whatever
I don't really need it at this point
If I actually needed any of the secrets to get buffs and stuff then
I would be pretty pathetic but I'm not at that juncture just yet
Mkay
Nothin
Alright I have a f- ooooh hello! Did I find a secret?
Oh nope that was-
Yep... I just
This is just...
(Incoherent gurgles)
Oh no! I activated your trap card!
Oh shit
Hey Buddy... How you doin'?
I'm gonna super shotgun you
Oh fuck you
Who did that?
Who the hell...
(Mark regurgitates... something...)
You running... Susan
(robotic sound?)
Ok, fine!
I'll play on your level
Hey Buddy
Oooooh shit!
Well you missed me
BOINK!
Yeah, this can like blast 'em
If I get two headshots with the super shotgun on those guys
Whoa hey...
What the frick are you doing?
Don't even try that
(Mr. Iplier speaks whale)
So mad about everything
Okay...
Well so far the big battle hasn't been triggered but I don't know why
Alright, whatever. Lets d--
Ohhp!
That sounds like a thing
That's sounds like the games have begun
Who's up here?
Hey buddy, ho-hooo!
Ha-hah!
Oh shit
Not dead yet
What the fuck?
This is supposed to be badass. Thank you.
I'm tryna be diverse
I'm trying to be different
Fuck you
Alright.
*Mark's mosquito mating call*
Nope. Alright...
Wuaah
Screw this >:(
This is stupid
I'm going back to ol' faithful
I'm not getting that quad just yet
I just...I wanted to look at it.
You know? Get close to it.
Tantalizingly so.
(demonic screams in the background)
Stop
wearing away my armor, you dick (wow Mark)
Thank you! :3
Huop
Hiyap!
*Manly worried Ahs*
BOINK!
okay
Let's see...
Oooh!
Ah there's just so many of 'em
They're everywhere
Uh-oh
That don't seem good
How 'bout this?
*the ancient song the wild Mark is using to attract its pray towards him*
Okay
Waah
*the second version ancient song the wild Mark is using to attract its pray towards him*
Dammit
There we go
Hadtha!
Hadada!
Nanana!
Okay there we go
Boink!
(METAL MUSIC)
Babadobah
bop bap bap bop
Missed meeeeeeeeeeee
Whadya gonna do 'bout it?
CRY?
Cry tears of b...
What are you doing over here?
I was gonna say CRY tears of BLOOD
but I was a little distracted by someone shooting a laser out of nowhere
Literally out of nowhere
hehehe
WHOA shit
fuck you
alright
Okay! I can dig this music.
I don't think when people hear this they're like
"I can dig this!"
"This is diggable!'
oh shiet
Hey
stop
stahp
stawhp
c'mon
Right in the butt!
There we go! Right in the butt.
Riiight in the butt.
I'm going to get the next one with a
graaaaah grah grah chainsaw
because..... I can.
OHH ANDIGOT THE  QUAAAD!!!
Alright, it's time for Quad destruction!
Sup...
Whoops, that was a little close.
God Damn it! I wasted all my shyit!
Alritght, QUAAAD!!
'Ey, QUAAD!
QUAAAAD!
Where's all the things to Quad Up?
God Damn It!
Why do I always get the QUAD at the wrong FRICKIN' times!!!!
SON OF A BISCUT!!
Awe this is such BullShit!
Such Bull Crap!
UHHHHHUU! *Sigh*
Ahhh FUCK OFF!
OH, This is such Ass!
What A waste of QUAD! GEEZ!!
I thought that was like the moment when the Pinkies were starting to coming out.
But that was going to be the moment when I NEEEDED it the most.
But apparently I'm just dumb..
And everything around me is smart..
Alright fine.
Just stop dude.
Woop..
Nope, there was a pillar in the way that time.
Kay.
Got it.
elehhh.
There we go! Gimme you!
I need some armor, thank you.
Ahha
Wooh!
There we go.. Okay.
Are we done?
Are we done?...
Oh! OHH! NOW! OH! AUWW What the FAA
I HATE THOSE THINGS!
Sooo much :.(
Ok, Gimme you.
Shiyit!
AWEEE, Right in the FAAACE!
OHHH, Right in the FAAACE!
OHHOHH! Again in the FAAACE!
Alright, Woop.
I need.. I need that,
I need, so many of these
I need to actually stun them.
Can I?
Can We?
CAN WEE!
There we go.. Ok
I need to do a lot more glory kills
Because I have a bad habit of absolutely annihilating
OHH! It's done! Ok!! I ff...
Man! That was just a...
Overall just...
Little..
They were peppering me the entire time
It was never actually a very, Crisis mode thing..
Ok whatever..
Soo..
And that little Battle arena, little blood gulch going on there.
doesn't seem like there's anything else
there might be something up there with that
I--I
I imagine
Oh my pointer's going there anyway.
Oooh! Nice decoration of the steps with.... Blood again.
Thank you, for all putting this up here
Outta my reach. Thats nice of you.
HEY! This looks cool!
Uuuumm!!!
Gross!
Are these your legs I'm about to climb on?!
Ok, here we go..
Hup!
Oh my god the well is peeeople!
Ahhhhhh!
Hu.
Hu!
Hu?
Yoink!
Let me just stick that in a little bit?!
Ehhh
Na-duhh--
I dont want to do too much damage
WHOA. Hey...
Ooooooaaaaauuuuhhhhhhh.
Hiii. Okay, Thank youuuuu?!
So? Are these like, my captured buddies?
Weeeell!
so they're not natural beings of hell?
they're just used to power this strange device...
I getcha.
I gotcha!
I understand
ah boing!
Okay
Soo
Now
I need to go elsewhere
Ahh okay.
Uuup through another skull.
I mean, I dont have a problem with this ordinarily but--woooo!
Who you talking to buddy?
Huh? Who ya talkin to?
You seem to be talking up a storm but you dont seem to be facing me at all
is that the spider mastermind at work there?
NO! Stop that...
Alright.
is there any other secrets that i might have missed?
I mean obviously behind that door, but i dont know how to open it
So let's go diving in,
Hello friends
Oooh hello
Whoa.
Fuck off
Hit. Heo.
Oh no! HEBEBE.
OWW Thats supposed to stun you?
Umm. ok,well, there we go
That's more like what was supposed to happen!
Aight whado we got?
Whado we got going on?
Armor? I'll take it.
annpshhh never mind i guess i wont take it
Hey I saw someone up there
Ha-I see somthing that I love!
Which is my baby berzerky
*Gasp*
mah berzerky babehh
Whoa what the
I think he died. I'm--Where tha frick did I, What the fuck is happening?
God Damn it! Why do I have to find all the bugs?
I just want to play the game normally
I just want to have a super cool , chill time
Oh where'd they go--you!?
Ok theres supposed to be a bajillion of you
Ahh oh there ya are
Thank you.
I heard you
I heard someone up here
Whoa! There ya are
Got him
Got you, HUEH
Alright, keep em coming. Keep em coming baby
I think that... I think he... woahohoho
Oh mah God
I think that one died
comah, Just..
I have a trouble climbing when i have this thing, God Damn it!
Alright he's dead.  Head's gone.
Whoa!
AHHH!
It's a thang
Huh (Fart noise)
Oh no, He's dead now!
Whoa his heada
HUUHH, Putha
Sorry, didn't mean to.
And by that I mean I totally meant to.
Cuz ya activated my trap card! >:3
Did I not suggest that enough
Oink.. XD
Hey what are you doing here?
UINK!! XD
UINK! XD
Oh, Nuhuho
what else we got? Oh you?
I just killed your friend, are you gonna be mad about that?
I mean you guys used to be humans
Above everything else here
Maybe all of these things used to be humans I have no idea
Boink!
OHohoh
Was that right in tha face?
that might not have been right in the face
I'm just kinda giving myself false expectations about thi--
WAOIIIIII... Okay
Thank you, needed that... ROCKET LAUNCHER TIME?
I agree, ROCKET LAUNCHER TIME indeed >:D
.............. I mean, if they're gonna play with Rocket Launchers, I betta (you said it Mark)
(in a random fake accent that I can't even distinguish) Oh, he ethploded right beforre meh :o
HEY, what are you doing over there?
Thank you :3
Man, there's a lot of little guys around
Thank youu
Good god... ueghhh.. Oh fuck
Fuck off! Hoh!
Whoa, oh jeez
Oh jeez x3
Oh gosh, oh jeez
HUNGHDUH
What's goin on? Someone
Tryna spawn in there? I dunno
Woo.. there we go
Ah, I shouldn't have let myself get low on health. I keep forgetting that
and then, that's what's gonna end up killing me
Later on
Things get even dicey-er
Which they always get...
RIGHT ABOUT NOW! Oh, fuck you
Shadow pinks... *boom*
Kay he's dead c:
I'm pretty sure he's dead, I think I was just blowing
his corpse away.  (he's dead Mark c'mon lol) Alright
Who wants a Gauss Cannon?? Someone?
Over there? Someone big?
I don't even care if you're just a Pinky, I-I'll use this
To take out a P-- ookay, it's a target
What the fuck hit me?
I don't know what did, but it blow up
*blast* Whoa, man that tosseded me back a bit.
Okay, heuppp!
Thank you :3 I need more health please
more more more more more more (get dat health Mark asap)
Ahhh fuck off
Ah shit
*blast* EEUP
EHHHHHHH... Boink! Okay!
Thank you! More health please, more health (get it together please Mark)
I don't wanna s- I'm like two shots
If I'm down this low, I'm two shots away
From dying.. Can't have dat, too risky >.<
Anybody?
C'mon!
Uhhhhhhhh
Okay!
*no response from the fellow demons or any other living being on Hell*
Alright!
Don't know where you went, I'll just try to try to go for the end goal.
..... What the fuck?
Why can't I get up there?
...Okie, ah there you are!
*blasts at fellow demon* Tryna run away from me!
... There we go, got him
O-Oh! Hello!
I have a present for- :D
OH NOOO-OHOH COME ON
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
WITH THAT BALONEY?
OHHH FUCK OFF MAN!
Ahhhh that was my fault
I fell at the wrong time
Wow, that was DICKETRY
That was a hundred percent DICKALACIOUS
Man...
DICKALICIOUS TO THE MAX ;3
Alright thank you
I know I am amazing at getting all of the weapons ;D
HEUP- *fart noise*
Lemme just pawnch this wit ma dagger
I'm gon get it, look at-
What the f- AWHOHH
Okay, so the game crashed and it, of course, reverted me back
before my awesome performance in killing everybody here
So watch as I blast away
Every demon that ever existed >:D
HEHBLEHBLIHBLOO
*Markimoo becomes a demon slaying chipmunk.*
*demonic chipmunk laughter*
Okay everything is dead now! :D
I didn't even use the
Berserk Pack
Cause I'm kewllllll 8D
Okay, I hope everybody had fun with THAT
Nooooooo, ohhhh
Shiiiiiit okay
Don't crash this time, please.
HEBEH EH BEH EH UH
*The struggle of putting in the dagger*
*The struggle continues* HEH DEUH!
Okay, I wanted to be a little more gentle with that
Hell was trying to reach through my computer
And stop me from being awesome
Oh I get it, yes point me the way
I know, I-I-I know
Alright.  "The Eme--Eleme--the--thee--the--"fuck...
Thi-th--fuuck... The-eh-the-bleuhhbl
*Finally lol*
*finishes stumbling through* Ah okay, whatever. Alright, movin' on!
Don't make me die
from crashing cause that's the equivalent of death
Alright, I'm gonna grab this
And I'm gonna bolt it through
And hopefully carry some Beserk
Into the realm of my enemies
FIGHT ME!~
FIIIIGHT MEH!!!
Fight me? Fight- anybody? Anybody wanna fight me?
Berserk is still going!
Beserk is still running! C'mon!
Fight me, fight me, somebody! Please I'm begging you
I-I-I-I'm begging ya!
Please, somebody! Anybody!
Taste my fists of fury! >:O
Taste my fists!
You had to- F-FIST TASTING!
Thank you! <3
My gosh, I thought no one was gonna appreciate all of the tasty fist
*That's what she said (   ͡° ͜ ʖ ͡ °)*
Eww
Thank you, yes, the Pinkies, I'm gonna get rid of you!
Whoa-hoo-hoo-hoo.. YES!
One last one! Thank you!
Goodness gracious! Can't believe that lasted!
Alright back to the murder! ^w^
I suppose ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
Timely murder this time
Whereas before it was already been done murdering
Y-y-you don't want that
I mean, technically it's still murder, right?
I mean, they're demons, but I--
I am killing them
What other definition would you put besides like
"slaughter" or something? Eh I don't know
I don't wanna get into the moral debate of
what the hell I'm doing is
Thank you.. Oh, hey
Alright, how are we doing?
Woooo
They're giving me a lot of Pinkies this time around
I'm not sure I appreciate it
Cause we got a like- this one seems like a more
Mobile battlefield
Than the one they were doing before
So they definitely want me to be running around all over the place
Someone come runnin over this explosive barrel
HUHBOOSKI! Oh why he kicked it out
of the way! He's too smart >_<
Oh he's after me! I'll never survive this encounter!
Thank you.
Oh wait never mind, I sur--
I--I mysteriously survived the encounter, what do you know.
There's not a lot of-
I'm--I was looking for armor the whole time I was running through
I may have missed it but I don't see-
I don't see a big deposit which is what I was really looking for
And I keep getting...keep getting peppered by fireballs
From a vast distance
Okay.. ooh what the fuck?
Where did I go- oooh woahohohoh
Alright, you know what? Fine!
I needed ammo anyway! Thank you!
And hopefully some armor
Alright... Ah fuck, not you-
Not you-I'm--SCREW IT
SCREW IT, CLOSE QUARTERS, WOOOOO
Don't! Stop! Jeez!
Okay, I'm going for it
Heup! Ehm 'ey!
Blablabla
Anybody else? Wablabla!
You're not- Ohhhhhh I did it again
I--it's-- It's a curse!
It's like a perpetual cur--
EVERY TIME I HIT THE QUAD
EVERY TIME, EVERY TIME I HIT THE QUAD
Things just- ARGEHHHHHAHEGH!!
quadded... quadded all over him
QUAD IT UP... QUAAAAAAAD!!!
QUAD- is he dead??
I couldn't tell... I qua--I quadded a lot
of quads... QUAAD
.... quad damage!
Quad- okay that was a waste of quad.
Uh-oh! Is that a big guy??
Too bad he's gonna die! >:D
Heup, yep, yep... he's dead
Whoa! Another one! Whooooa!
Nnnnnnnope!
Okay, whoa he's still alive? That's, that's-
Ohh shit.... Nnyooo I'm gonna die! D:
ONE MORE PEPPER AND I'M DONE FOR!
Whoa shit- Ahahahahaha!!
Nnnnnoo! Ahahahah!
Ohohohohooh
Hohohohoho *Marki-claus?*
hoh- shit!
FUCK ME! AHH NOTANOTHERONE!!
Blehlolehlolem!
*Mark continues the sacred killing chant*
Shootin' it anyway!!
Ooooohkay! Alright who wants to get-
Ch-eughh... AHH you!
Okay, alright I'll-I'll take it!
Woo! No come here, come here, come here
*fart killing noise* That was too close for comfort!
I don't like it :C
I'm not comfortable! I don't feeeel good. >.<
Alright, I killed them all!
Continually messing up the QUA
Just my destiny, but alas we're doing okay (That's the spirit, Mark! :D)
alright lemme get this last Elemental Wraith
And then we'll be able to withstand mah wrath >:3
Thank you for all the peppering up!
Uengh... thank you.
Appreciated. Much appreciated. <3
Okay, boink!
This very LIGHT touch.. don't crash the game!
Also, those things look like moons in their chests, it's weird.
Uh-huh KABOOMIE!
Did it! *creepy laughing in the distance*
Ahhhhh what was with the laughing? Huh?
Who's laughing?
*Mark reads the entry of The Wraiths III*
...For some reason--Yeah, that breaks every time I first go to it...
Okay I am very confused as
to WHO is WHO here.
Because...something's not exactly being translated properly
I don't know who the Betrayer is. Is he a denizen of Hell, is he betraying Hell?  Or he betraying the people that tried to protect us from Hell?
Like these dudes, like who do these stand for?
They all have the symbol that I do
So I'm assuming these are my bros
These are my bros~ And they must have been the ones that
were betrayed because they seem to be the DEAD ones
yeah... *awkward*
Anyway, alright! Well that seems...
interesting?
LET'S DO THIS! WOOOOOOOOOO!
Boink! :3
Owwwwww... Hiii~
Haven't seen you in a while, how you doing?
OH OH OH OH OH OH OH!
Uh-huh.  Okay.
*Olivia has a huge demon orgasm*
...Cool?
Uh-oh...
Euhh...
I'm sure I'll see you again real soon in a more horrific form! :D
Uh-huh.. OH SHNAP
OH SHIT IT'S THE SPIDER MASTERMIND!
Hell yeah! Oh man, I didn't know that she was gonna be transformed into that!
That's coooool!
That's KEEWWL!
Alright, lemme get--Hang on, I gotta get the right weapon for this!
Oh, shit, I forgot.  This isn't gonna do shit to you.
OWIE!  OWAH!
OW-AH!
Lemme get my bearings, jee--WHOA, WHAT THE FUCK'RE YOU??
Oh god!
Oh, this is way different than just the Minigun-r-havin' Spider Mastermind that I--o-of yore.
Holy shit.
Yeeep--boink.  Whoa.
God dammit!  That laser.
I'm not ready for it!
Ehh.
Alright, I-I'm not gonna win this time around, I'm probly gonna die...before I have any possibility of--
WHOA!  Cool moves, bruh!
Cool moves!
Why'd you do that, bruh?
Why??
Not sure I understand your...reasoning--whoa!
Hi.  Okay, thank you.  I'm gonna go...  I'm gonna go...over here.
Oh, that dudn--that dud...tha-that theemth...theemth eh--bad.
Okay, you know what?  I'm gonna just...I'm gonna just...just--theere we go.
Habedeh-habedeh-habedeh-habedeh.
Woop!  God damn!  Fuck the overheat, I'm just gonna use the regular one, because at this point...
I can't seem to get it right anyway.
hebedeh-hebedeh-hebedeh-hebedeh...
I'm gonna just aim for the giant gelatinous exposed brain!
It seems like it might be a weakness!  I'm not a hundred percent sure but...y'know here we go anyway!
Who knows a--wh-who knows anything...really?  Who knows?
Uh oh!  Hit a pillar.
Good thing these pillars are here.  Keep giving me health.
Maybe--maybe she's weak to like the pistol or something.
Yeeah, this--this is doin' it.  Yeap, that's--that's--that's doin' it.
Okay, this--she seems to be weak to this.  If I get this right in her brain...
Wait, it's doing a lot of damage if I get it like riiight--oh, in her face!
Ohhh, THAT'S what I should be aiming for, directly on her fa--eu~ughh...
Yeah, just keep doin' that!  That's workin'!  It'll get me eventually, don't worry about it, it's cool.
Alright, so if I just--nope, outta that...
Only thing I got left is Super--is Shotgun ammo, so...
Good ole' Reliable.
I kinda feel like I got her stuck on a loop!
She seems to just be doin' the same thing over and over again.
I mean, I'm fine with it.
If-if that's all she wants to do, if that's all the potential that--I'm literally out of everything.
AHH I got the BFG!
FUCK OFF!
Fuck off with you.
Oh, shit.  Ack, stood right in the...  Alright, that did a thing!
Well, that's good.  I wish I had somethin' else to shoot her with when she was weak.
But, alas--ow, again, with that--ow!  Stop that.
Ah!  Ag--how am I supposed to evade that, when she's lookin' at me the whole time?
Shit.  This ain't good.
Ah gahd, AH gahd!  Ah gahd. Ah gahd!  Ah, ah, ah--OH god!  Ohh god!!
Ah!  I j--is this what I'm supposed to do?  Oh fuck, I'm dead.
I'm dead...I'm dead.  Oh, THANK you.  Finally!
I appreciate it!
Oh god, oh god, she's gonna--Oh god.  OH god, she's doin' a thing!
Oh god, get up, get up!  Okay, I got i--I ge--I understand!
I understand!  I understand!  I understand!
Oh, that ain't good.  Whoa--hello!
Is this how we're gonna do this?  Oh, shit!  Well that i--that's...the opposite of what I wanted.
Ah, shit, I'm dead.  I'm dead, aren't I?
OHH, I'm gonna die right here at the end!
Oh, shit.
Hoh--hoh!  Hoh!  HOOH!!
HOHH!!  Get dead!  GET RIPPED!  GET WRECKED!!
WRECK WRECK WRECK WRECK WRECK WRECK WRECK!!!
WREEEECK!!!
Oh shit!!  OHHH!
Olivia!  *chuckle*  I hardly knew ya!
Euhhh, I didn't know the brain was supposed to pulse like that.  Eh, probly not.
Okay!  Blrlr-pphr--Lemme just--here, uh, you need your inspection!
Oho, I didn't know I had any ammo left!
Niiihihihice!
YEHEHEHEHEAH!
HOLY shit!
Alrighty then!
WOOooh...
I got Goldguy.
Still pulsa--OOOHHH-WAAAOHH!!
I wanted to look at my...my...my prize... ;_;
*Samuel Hayden says something in the background*
What'd you say, Samuel?
Mr. Hayden?
...Uh-huh...
This guy better not lock me away again.
Hello!
Uh-huh.
Oh!  That's...I didn't, uh... I didn't kn--
YOOU bastard!
Ahh, shit!
I activated YOUR Trap Card!
GOD DAMMIT!
Oh, okay.  But I-I *laugh* expected that to happen.
That's why I put the thing in my, uh...my, my suit anyway.
But, th--I--ga--geh--I--it's--at the end, it just dawned on me, that's like the end of the game!
OH SHIT.
*silence*
Is that the end??
I think so!  Whoa, hey.  How's it goin'?
I think that's the end of the game, this must be just like creative ending credits, or something like that.
YAAAAAY!  =D  YAY! *applause*
I will say...uh, while we watch this; I have had a phenomenemally fun time playing this game.
It has been a delight.
From start to finish...I love this game.  It's exactly what it said it was gonna be.
Which, it was just ripping, and tearing...
Until the job is done, and holy shit, look at the size difference.
I didn't even think I was gonna beat her on the first try, but apparently ah did, 'cause ah'm aowesome.
So, thank you everybody for joining me on this adventure.  This was a great time.
I'm willing to bet, at the end of the credits here, there's gonna be something, but I'll wrap it up here.
Just so I can get it out of the way, and give my opinions about the game.
This game...
As a fan of the original DOOM, there are some things that I would disagree with,
and there's a lot of things that I would agree with.  Let me just start with what I agree with, obviously.
I agree that this game is definitely reminiscent of what DOOM was.
If they were setting out to set the stage of DOOM for what it was, for a new generation,
I think they accomplished the goal in an enormous way.  It is a phenomenal game.
It was phenomenally fun...the entire way through.  It had great feel to it.  It had the right, like, sense to it.
It had everything right, in the right way, that it was just perfect...for that purpose, for recreating the feel.
Not perfect overall, but recreating that feel, I think they nailed it.
A hundred percent nailed the brutality of it, the victoriousness of it,
the unstoppable nature of this DOOM guy, that sets him...to what we've always known!
DOOM guy is a b--...like, a...guy to, like--there's NO stopping DOOM guy.
Like, it's unbelievable how much, like...fuckin' destruction this guy brings,
and it was just sooo good to channel that through the game.
Now... Level design-wise, also good.
It felt very, uh, interesting with...y'know, the UAC and Hell, although I will admit, Hell started to get very samey.
For as, like, diverse and faceted as it was it was very easy to get lost.
'Cause everything kinda looked the same.
But, maybe that was the point, 'cause the level design was supposed to be very open.
And I kinda agree with that, that should be emphasized, and I like that because...
It allowed you to take your own path through the game, and it allowed you to, uh, decide what to do first.
If you wanted to go do the secrets, you could do that.
If you just wanna go play through the game and get to the end, you could do that too.
Still fun, no matter what.  You play the way you wanna play, even though you ta--you take your set pieces-*burp*
But in those set pieces, you do what you wanna do.
Now... Wh-what I would...l-have liked to have seen more out of this game...
Is some more...
story innovation.
Ah--i-i--ah-i--okay...I-I'm always very hesitant about criticism, because I wanna be--
I wanna make sure that I'm not misunderstood on what I think is wrong with the game, and--
and, I'm not saying anything is wrong with the game.  I don't think I could've done something better.
But, what I would've liked to see is...
We all know DOOM.  Like, we know it.  Wh-fans of DOOM, we know DOOM.  And this is DOOM.
Definitely DOOM, it's great.
That's adorable, that's frickin' cute.  XD
But...
I don't feel like they added more, and I don't feel like they connected the set pieces from what has come before...
What they went for was just a recreation of DOOM,
and to reinvigorate the series and bring it to the next generation.  And they did that, like I said...
Thaaat is kick-ass!  =D That is killer!
That is awesome.
That...that's--oh, yeah.  You gotta do that, I've seen that outta the trailer, but...damn.
But...I don't feel like they brought enough new to the table.
I mean, obviously they had...y'know, the new characters,
and like, the motivation, but that was all to drive the story of what was in here.
What I wanted was more...of the why.
Like, I still don't know what the deal with the timeline is of this DOOM guy,
And who--Who gave him the armor?  Who did all this stuff??  Who-wh-who was all this??
Like, there's...there's a lot of unanswered questions, and I-I bet they're...what they're doing is...
Kinda like what Star Wars: The Aw--uh, The Force Awakens did.
They created kind of a recreation of Episode IV...to open up for more.
So, this is like the reintroduction of DOOM, so that they can expand it more in the sequels that are to come.
And I would love to see sequels, but at the same time...I feel like they could have had more in this one...
Instead of waiting for the next ones.  But, they have a whole new generation to try to open this up to.
I am an old fan.  Of course I want more.
That's who I am, I've been...like, eagerly awaiting this type of game to come out for 20 years, so...
Of course I'm not gonna be satisfied.  That's where my bias comes into play,
and I'm not entirely right in saying that, so...because of my perspective.
From a new character coming into this...or, new character--a new player coming into this, this is amazing.
And this is so much fun.  And, oddly, it's different from what's out there right now in the shooter world.
But that's a good thing.
Because it's reinvigorating what it used to be... The brutality of it, the fast pace...
Just the bloody action, which is awesome.
So!  I think I got all my words out!
Probably in another ramble that doesn't make a whole lot of sense.
So, the only thing left to do is wait 'til the end of the credits and see what happens, if anything.
So...here we go.
I guess that was it!  It ended, and there was nothing.  I had to check it up.  I didn't see anything.
Maybe on Ultra-Nightmare, because I don't know if the, uh... I don't know if that's open yet.
I don't even know what this would do.
"Mission Select," ohh...  Go back to it all.
Lemme see this... "Start Campaign"...
"Ultra-Nightmare."  Oh my god.  "If you die your campaign is OVER"?
EUUHHH!  I dunno if I'd EVER be ready for that.
That's not even something you livestream.
Holy shit, you die once?
Man!  I died on Ultra-Violence.
I mean, I could...I could play it on Nightmare.  I-I don't doubt that I could beat the game on Nightmare.
I wasn't even focusing half the time on Ultra-Violence, so...
It--that's something for another person to do, not me.
So--and maybe there's something in the end credits, a super bonus if you beat it on Ultra-Nightmare...
I bet there is.  So...I'll leave to anyone else.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
Thank you for joining me on this journey, I always love doing these longer let's plays.
They kinda give me something to look forward to each day.
And, uh...I don't know what the next game that I'm gonna be-de-be doing, that's gonna be a long let's play.
But I'll take your suggestions down in the comments below, if you wanna give me some idea.
Especially for upcoming, future games as well.
So, THANK you everybody so much for watching!
And as always...I will see YOU in the next video!
Bye-bye!  =D
*DOOM music outro!*